(upbeat music)
- [Jake] Ooh.
When I first started treasure hunting
I would come down to the river
pretty much every single day
and surf and raft and have
a good time at the river.
But the first time I
went underneath the water
it just opened my eyes to a
world I didn't know existed.
My name is Jake Koehler.
I'm a free diver and treasure hunter.
You guys ready?
- Let's do it.
- I'm ready man.
- Let's do it man.
I dive in the Chattahoochee
River in Columbus, Georgia
which is one of the world's largest
urban whitewater courses ever built.
So this is actually Georgia
and the other side of
the river is Alabama.
Thousands of people go down
this river every single year
and they lose all kinds of valuables
and it's a lot of fun
to go out there and swim
and see if I can find
some stuff they've lost.
(mellow jazz music)
Some of the most interesting
things I've found
definitely have to be like
iPhones, GoPros, pistols.
(water bubbling)
(laughing)
Always pretty interesting
to find a potential murder
weapon out here in the river,
but GoPros and phones,
definitely my favorite finds.
When I find these cameras and phones
I try to just figure out who it belongs to
because not only like finding
this stuff is a lot of fun,
but giving back the
devices that they've lost
is also a blast.
Here you go buddy.
- [Police Officer] Be careful out here.
- I will.
Not only you find a lot of cool stuff
that people lose after rafting,
but thousands upon thousands
of fishermen come up here
and normally no one would go out there
and collect all these fishing lures,
but I go out there and I'll
free them from the wall,
free them from the stumps
and it just kind of cleans up the area
and I get free fishing lures.
There's a lot of animals
underneath the water.
You've got a lot of striped
bass, shad, spotted bass
and catfish.
You see a lot of turtles down here too.
It's just super beautiful
to see all that stuff.
- [Diver] Okay first day
back and Jake finds a GoPro.
He was diving right next to me.
- I was really surprised how
many people were interested
in watching treasure hunting videos.
Someone said hey?
Hey, we've got another fan over there.
I love coming down here, look for treasure
and surfing and have a good time
but I didn't know I could
actually do this as like
a full time job.
I started my YouTube channel
and recorded myself swimming
and having a good time at the river
and one thing led to another
and now I'm able to do this
as my full time job.
- [Man] Oh my god.
Twenty more, twenty more.
Oh it's going quick bro.
Two more.
(friends cheering)
You did it man.
- The more I travel the more
I realize that this spot
is actually one of a kind.
There's not many places in the
world that you can actually
surf at a river, you could
fish and treasure hunt.
I have a love for this river, man.
I just can't stay inside.
I have to go down and have a good time.
(laughing)
(upbeat music)